[Aplausos]
o mundo tá tão apressado hoje que
perdemos a capacidade de enxergar o
outro
já no universo da deficiência visual
notar o outro se torna essencial para a
sua segurança
não eu não sou deficiente visual
eu sou alice e desenvolve um trabalho
junto com pessoas com deficiência visual
junto com meus sócios é a mais de dez
anos
formamos e capacitamos centenas de
pessoas com deficiência visual cegas e
de baixa visão a se tornarem
massoterapeutas o nosso objetivo não é
apenas ensinar uma técnica de massagem
que nós queremos é despertar o cuidador
que existe dentro de cada um de nós
nesses ensinamentos
eles aprendem a usar o poder do toque da
mão ea cultura milenar
através desse toque aprendem a se
relacionar com outras pessoas ea sentir
eles atendem um único dia
dezenas de pessoas no atendimento de
massagens pessoas que chegam estressadas
cansadas com dores e conseguem aliviar
essas dores fazendo um atendimento com
respeito e compaixão
dessa forma eles estão contribuindo para
a sociedade
e assim começa a verdadeira inclusão
sempre me perguntam por que você faz
esse trabalho
se tem alguém cego na família
eu fico me questionando será que as
pessoas acham que ensinar cego a fazer
massagem é uma novidade a primeira
instituição para cegos exceção
paulo na década de 30 ensinava massagem
na década de 50
o primeiro cego com carteira assinada
foi uma saia justa para os fãs de
futebol foi no são paulo futebol clube
que contratou hammam e lá ele se
aposentou
na verdade assim o que a gente faz e fez
foi reativar o mercado de trabalho que
estava adormecido e criamos
possibilidades de geração de renda para
centenas de pessoas com deficiência
visual que na sua grande maioria perde a
visão na fase adulta e passam a ser
vistas como inúteis pela sociedade
eu acredito que a gente se desenvolve em
maior escala
quando a gente vive e compartilha com
pessoas na diversidade
por isso que quando me perguntam por que
eu faço esse trabalho
hoje eu sei por que essas pessoas têm um
potencial enorme em uma troca com
fantástica de experiências e se a
deficiência visual é adquirida na fase
adulta
isso poderia ser você poderia ser seu
pai poderia ser eu que somos pessoas com
potencial enorme de contribuição mas que
ficaríamos à margem da sociedade e ainda
nos dias de hoje muitos deficientes
visuais ficam fechados nas suas casas
porque a sociedade não está pronta para
recebê los
só no brasil há mais de seis milhões e
meio de pessoas com alguma
a ciência visual na estatística
esse número irá dobrar até 2020
nesses anos todos convivendo com as
pessoas com deficiência visual
houve centenas de histórias histórias
com ensinamentos que eu procuro trazer
um pouquinho pra minha vida
histórias como da luzia que nasceu com
uma doença congênita e aos dois anos de
idade já havia perdido mais de 70% da
visão e ficou cega aos 20 anos de idade
luzia quase não saía de casa e nunca
tinha trabalhado
ela veio até nós e fez o nosso curso de
massagem
logo em seguida ela foi contratada por
uma multinacional como uma terapeuta
trabalha lá há três anos ela não ficou
só por ali ela resolveu retomar os
estudos
fez curso técnico de massoterapia à
noite porque durante o dia ela
trabalhava e ainda não está satisfeita
se preparando para o curso de psicologia
e isso a gente incentiva com a luzia eu
aprendi determinação e força
como aprendi com a crise e superação e
coragem que ficou cega e logo após ficar
cega foi abandonada pelo marido tendo
três filhos pequenos para criar a crise
não tinha nem mobilidade ainda não sabia
nem utilizar bengala
por isso ela não conseguia levar os
filhos até o ponto de ônibus para eles
poderem pegar o ônibus pra ir pra escola
mas essa mulher venceu ela assim poder
ou de uma coragem que eu acho que nem
ela sabia que tinha enfrentou todas as
barreiras da cegueira a barreira social
inclusive a da maternidade
a crise nos procurou com 44 anos
querendo fazer o curso de massagem e
hoje com dinheiro
ganhando os atendimentos que faz com a
massagem ajuda o filho mais velho
concluir a faculdade e ajuda a pagar o
curso técnico do filho mais novo com
essas histórias
o que mais me surpreende é que ainda
hoje no brasil menos de 6% das pessoas
com deficiência visual é empregada na
área que desenvolvo das centenas pessoas
já formadas mais de 80% estão no mercado
de trabalho a cada cinco segundos uma
pessoa fica cega no mundo
a primeira dificuldade
quando uma pessoa se encontra na
condição de deficiente visual em
permanência o meu caso do stanley que
aos 11 anos de idade teve um aneurisma
cerebral e no pós cirúrgico tudo ok
estava no pós cirúrgico
ele teve duas paradas cardíacas e voltou
segue com um desempenho com os
procedimentos corretos com assistência
médica aos poucos ele foi recuperando
parte dessa visão
ele se tornou um baixa visão um visão
subnormal para um adolescente só a
própria adolescência já é confusa
os famosos aborrecentes mas com a
deficiência visual um pouquinho mais
complicado
hoje isso também tem 20 anos e
recentemente ele teve um apagão na visão
e ficou cego do nada
assim acordou de lá pra cá ele convive
efetivamente com a permanência porque
ora ele consegue enxergar um pouco na
hora ele está cego
é difícil né a gente imaginar uma
situação dessa a gente não consegue e
por isso que esse trabalho que nós
fazemos a gente gostaria de dividir com
vocês e também dividimos com todos
aqueles que nos procuram que cada evento
que nós fazemos cada viagem a trabalho
que foi que vamos cada reunião que
participamos
a gente sabe que a gente acredita que a
gente está plantando hoje ser acolhido
amanhã pelas crianças que hoje nascem
cegas mas que daqui a 15 20 anos
encontraram uma sociedade mais justa
mais acessibilidade com mais condições
de trabalho e principalmente respeito
não tem como falar de respeito se
lembrar de uma história sou dalmir só
dormiram senhor de 70 anos de idade
cego num determinado sábado chuvoso a
gente tinha um evento pra fazer era
muito cedo eu confesso pequim com uma
preguiça horrorosa mas foi também o
evento e antes passei no meu próprio
tenha o seu domingo quando ele entrou no
carro
a primeira pergunta que eu fiz eu dormir
só não sente preguiça de sair de casa
num dia chuvoso e frio tão cedo assim
ele sorriu e disse eu sinto mas quando
eu ouço os pássaros cantando eu me
alegro porque eu sei que lá fora onde é
que merece ser vivido aprender muita
coisa
a condição do deficiente visual
ele é 99%
cível mas a visão da sociedade essa sim
ela pode e ela deve mudar
obrigado
[Aplausos]